today in america there really is only
one unforgivable sin
and that is to deviate from the accepted
script when speaking of protected
identity groups
it is to say something whether
intentionally or not
that either offends protected identity
groups or that the elites find offensive
on their behalf
what i think is important to grasp from
the outset is that identity politics
today
is not just the dominant ideology when
it comes to civil rights
it's the dominant ideology in america
period if you look at prominent
politicians professors
producers pundits fortune 500 ceos tech
gurus journalists
all of the famous credentialed and
successful people who comprise our
ruling class
they either all affirm the tenants of
identity politics or at the very least
are deferential to them americans are
now divided into favored and disfavored
groups
and civil rights law we are told should
not apply to the favored groups identity
politics is demanding that we judge
people not by the content of their
character
but by the color of their skin their sex
and their sexual orientation
and it demands that we do so in
perpetuity
it rejects the principle of what james
madison once called
equal rights under equal laws and it
instead demands that we build a modern
caste system that privileges some groups
over others in our laws and culture
identity politics is not answering the
question
who am i although it does have an answer
to that question
its primary focus rather is the much
deeper question of
why is there evil in the world
and identity politics provides a clear
and unambiguous answer
because of straight white men identity
politics takes and modifies the
christian teaching on sin and now no
longer applies to everyone but only to
the oppressor groups but here's the more
important modification
it offers no hope of salvation or of
redemption from sin
equal group outcomes are now the measure
of equal opportunities between groups
and under this logic
all disparities can only have one
explanation discrimination all
disparities are blamed on discrimination
and anyone who suggests otherwise is
immediately called a sexist and a racist
in order to silence dissent and stimi
inquiry
and here of course ultimately is the
great paradox of this focus on group
results
it requires discrimination in order it
says to eliminate discrimination
if you focus on results this will
inevitably lead you to deny positions to
some people on the basis of their skin
color their race their ethnicity their
sex their sexual orientation you name it
the main reason that identity politics
exerts such a powerful poll in america
is because it suggests that we can
either embrace identity politics
or remain callously indifferent to the
well-being of fellow americans who
happen not to look like us
this in truth is a false choice
identity politics should be rejected not
because it demands justice for those who
have been unjustly treated
but because it poses a threat to
republican self-government
by corroding patriotic ties
and demanding special treatment rather
than equality under the law
you